tami a thought leader and an influencer
is someone who's not just talking about
how to do things but they're actually
doing things and then teaching others
how to do it so for me entrepreneurs are
wonderful potential thought leaders
because they've already figured out how
to solve a problem and then they're
sharing that solution with others but if
you're an executive or your social
entrepreneur whatever it might be it's
figuring out how to codify develop a
how-to guide or framework a methodology
something that you can then turn over as
your intellectual property and spread it
into the world so it's gotta find what
you know sharing those best practices
with others that to me is will thought
leaders and those are the people that
should have the influence because they
have the big ideas thought leadership is
the very best career insurance around
what's going to happen in your future
career is that something is going to
change there's going to be a merger
there's gonna be an acquisition your
party is gonna be out of power or your
boss is going to leave whatever it might
be that you thought was the next path
that's not going to be open to you at
some point thought leadership actually
allows others to find you and to provide
you the next opportunity it allows you
to land on your feet and actually allows
you to know the right people to connect
with so that you can make that next
opportunity happen it's no longer about
waiting around and hoping that
something's happening being a thought
leader actually makes things come to you
and makes the opportunities appear that
to me is the career insurance we all
need
what I would start with for example is
literally hosting a brown-bag lunch at
your company what is it you know more
about than anybody else could you host a
small training for just a small team of
people is there some sort of a community
event where your knowledge and
information that you might know that
somebody else might not know might be a
value is there some sort of a small
group of people that you can bring
together and start testing your ideas
what people don't realize that speakers
don't suddenly come up with their
brilliant ideas the first day they get
on a giant stage they test them over and
over again with lots of with lots of
people so you want to play the small
venues the second thing is you want to
actually figure out what is it you
actually know that other people don't
know now that can be very difficult when
you're early in your career but we've
all had lessons learned somewhere in
college somewhere in a book we read
somewhere and a box gave us and being
able to internalize that and then share
with folks how did that occur in your
life okay great you learned to go do XYZ
at a book but then when do you actually
implemented that what's the situation
what was that experience like can you
share that with other people to a more
generalizable lesson that's when you
actually start having something to say
people tend to overlook the actual
experience that they've had and not see
those are things that can actually help
the next group of people there are
always some there was always someone
younger than you who's or someone who's
never done what you've done before that
you can help along and that gives you
the confidence to keep doing it for
bigger and thicker audiences